die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen an diesem
vierten advent an meiner seite ist für
den sport norbert lehmann einen sponsor
von mir und das sind die themen von
heute
aus sorge vor micon die niederlande
gehen in den lock down und auch in
deutschland wird darüber diskutiert
wahl ohne hoffnung auf demokratie in
hongkong stehen nur china treue
kandidaten auf den stimmzetteln
und gedenken am berliner
breitscheidplatz fünf jahre nach dem
anschlag auf den weihnachtsmarkt
erinnert deutschland an die opfer
zumindest über weihnachten wird es hier
keinen lockdown geben das sagt der
gesundheitsminister heute doch gerade
eben kam der bericht des expertenrats
der bundesregierung seine empfehlung
schnelle kontakt beschränkungen die
omikron variante würde sich
explosionsartig verbreiten es drohten
flächendeckende arbeitsausfälle in
kritischer infrastruktur wie etwa der
polizei die bundesregierung stuft
großbritannien ab morgen als
virusvarianten gebiet ein gabriela la he
in london herrscht wieder der
katastrophenfall omikron die
hochansteckende mutante des corona virus
ist in england zur dominierenden
variante geworden sie macht 60 prozent
aller fälle im land aus und sie
verbreitet sich besonders rasant wie der
vergleich mit der zuvor dominierenden
delta variante am beispiel london zeigt
deutschland zieht konsequenzen ab morgen
ist großbritannien virusvarianten gebiet
wer von dort einreist muss 14 tage in
quarantäne
unabhängig von imf oder genießen den
status auch die niederlande ziehen die
omikron reißleine seit heute morgen gilt
ein strenger lockdown den schließt der
gesundheitsminister für deutschland in
der ard vorerst noch ausnahmen lockdown
also wie in den niederlanden vor
weihnachten den werden wir hier nicht
haben aber tatsächlich ist es so wir
werden eine fünfte welle bekommen
wichtigstes mittel im kampf gegen
omikron das impfen durch sonderaktionen
wie diesen drive-in im fränkischen
feuchtwangen soll das tempo erhöht
werden 30 millionen impfungen des jahres
er hatte kanzler stolz versprochen
generalmajor neuer chef des corona
krisenstabs im kanzleramt glaubt das
lässt sich machen
wir haben jetzt 24 millionen 418.000 540
menschen geimpft und jetzt noch knapp
zwei wochen zeit die 30 millionen sind
zu schaffen gegen eine mögliche
impfpflicht gingen in mehreren städten
wieder zahlreiche menschen auf die
straße in nürnberg hatte die afg zu
einer kundgebung aufgerufen
fraktionschefin weidl wirft der
regierung wortbruch vor
[Applaus]
es gibt keine
die demonstration blieb friedlich aber
beobachter berichten von einer
aggressiven stimmung
der expertenrat hatte gerade seine
empfehlungen vorgelegt theo koll in
berlin auf was müssen wir uns einstellen
ja die stellungnahme des expertenrats
ließ sich dramatisch und ist eine sehr
ernste warnung selbst der betrieb von
kritischer infrastruktur also auch von
krankenhäusern scheint demnach gefährde
bereits in den kommenden tagen so die
experten müsse es zu kontakt
beschränkungen kommen die
bundesregierung wird darauf reagieren
müssen sei es jetzt schon mit maßnahmen
unterhalb eines harten lockdown oder mit
massiven maßnahmen nach weihnachten die
chefs der staatskanzleien werden sich
schon morgen zusammenschalten mehrere
ministerpräsidenten fordern ja ein bund
länder fahrplan noch vor weihnachten
nach dieser expertenanalyse dürfte der
auch nötig sein
dankeschön für diese information und
berlin theo koll war das
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht hat
auf ihrer ersten auslandsreise den
baltischen staaten solidarität gegenüber
russland zugesichert bei einem besuch
des nato partners litauen hob sie die
bedeutung einer glaubhaften abschreckung
hervor sie betonte aber auch dass
konflikte mit russland diplomatisch
beigelegt werden sollten
nach hongkong dort wurde heute ein neues
parlament gewählt zum ersten mal nach
der niederschlagung der
demokratiebewegung
doch von einer freien wahl kann nicht
die rede sein denn peking hat das
wahlrecht in der chinesischen
sonderverwaltungszone verschärft nur
wenige gingen wir mehr dazu von alfra
das chinesische staatsfernsehen
vermeldet stolz nur währung kommen liebt
darf heute gewählt werden denn
zugelassen sind nur sogenannte patrioten
als kandidatin die loyal zu pekings
machthabern stimme
ich habe klare ziele für die wahl
definiert wir wollen sicherstellen dass
nur noch patrioten hongkong verwalten
und das haben wir erreicht
das staatsfernsehen zeigt lange
schlangen vor den wahllokalen
sie sollen die unterstützung der
hongkonger belegen aber unsere aktuellen
bilder zeigen dass es wohl wesentlich
weniger menschen sind die ihre stimme
abgeben ein boykott ist die einzige
möglichkeit gegen diese wahl zu
protestieren
wer die abschaffung der demokratie
kritisiert will unerkannt leiden ich bin
so sein so enttäuscht und ganz ohne
hoffnung
[Musik]
viele ehemalige demokratische
abgeordnete haben hongkongs machthaber
festgenommen einige sind ins ausland
geflohen nur die können noch sagen was
vielen hongkong denke
in kiel hat sich vorgenommen demokratie
neu zu definieren sie wollen der welt
vormachen hongkong ginge es besser diese
wahl gehört zur inszenierung
hongkong hat seinen sonderstatus
endgültig mit dieser wahl verloren
pekings machthaber haben die stadt auf
linie gebracht
chile wählt einen neuen präsidenten und
steht vor einer richtungsentscheidung im
ersten wahldurchgang lag der
ultra-konservative deutschstämmige jose
antonio castro ab vorn er verspricht vor
allem mehr sicherheit sein kontrahent
ist ein ehemaliger anführer der
studentenproteste
der erst 35 jahre alte gabriel borisch
hinter ihm steht ein linkes bündnis
vor genau fünf jahren gegen 20 uhr kam
der islamistische terror nach berlin auf
dem breitscheidplatz ein attentäter
raste mit einem lkw in den
weihnachtsmarkt und tötete zwölf
menschen vor zwei monaten kam ein
weiteres opfer dazu
ein ersthelfer starb an den folgen
seiner schweren verletzungen
viele überlebende sind traumatisiert und
kämpfen bis heute um unterstützung im
moment beginnt die gedenkveranstaltung
in der gedächtniskirche carsten behrendt
weil wir angehörigen trauern ich stehe
hier weil ich getröstet werde durch den
segnenden goldenem christus im blauen
licht dieser kirche zu beginn der
andacht bewegende worte von der mutter
eines berliner terror opfers draußen vor
der gedächtniskirche raste 2016 ein
attentäter mit einem lastwagen in den
weihnachtsmarkt 13 tote fast 100
verletzte danach zeigte sich deutschland
war auf den umgang mit einem solchen
anschlag nicht ausreichend vorbereitet
die hinterbliebenen beklagen jetzt in
einem offenen brief an die neue
bundesregierung nach wie vor vermissen
wir einen würdigen umgang mit den
betroffenen und hinterbliebenen des
anschlags sowie dessen umfassende
aufklärung janine hat bei dem anschlag
ihre mutter verloren es entsetzt sie
dass der attentäter vor der tat lange im
visier der behörden war aber wegen
fataler fehleinschätzungen nicht
gestoppt worden ist noch immer seien zu
viele fragen offen
[Musik]
das gefühl habe es wurde voll umfänglich
aufgeklärt so wie es seit auch
versprochen wurde justizminister
buschmann und vizekanzler habeck haben
weitere aufklärung zugesagt um 20 uhr
zwei dem zeitpunkt der tat soll mit 13
glockenschlägen an jedes der todesopfer
erinnert werden
und jetzt zum wintersport norbert wieder
mit deutschen erfolgen im zweierbob der
frauen etwa und im vierer der männer ja
und skispringer karl geiger der hätte es
wie schon gestern auch heute fast wieder
ganz oben aufs siegerpodest im
schweizerischen engelberg geschafft der
28 jährige übernahm nach dem zweiten
sprung mit 131 meter die führung musste
sich dann aber rio kobayashi geschlagen
geben der japaner der landete bei 136
meter trotzdem eine gelungene
generalprobe des oberstdorfer für die
vierschanzentournee geiger weiterhin
erster in der weltcup gesamtwertung
im ersten sonntagsspiel der fußball
bundesliga gewinnt freiburg gegen
leverkusen mit 2 2 1 die preisgabe
verdrängen dadurch bayer vom dritten auf
den vierten platz
und erstmals ist ein deutsches profi
liga spiel gegen rassismus vorfälle
abgebrochen worden bei der drittliga
begegnung duisburg gegen osnabrück wurde
vfl profi aaron opoku offenbar von
zuschauern beleidigt der schiedsrichter
unterbrach die partie beide mannschaften
beschlossen dann aber in der kabine zu
bleiben der msv sprach vom tiefpunkt in
der vereinsgeschichte ein mutmaßlicher
täter wurde bereits identifiziert
kür der besten deutschen athletinnen und
athleten die wahl zum sportler des
jahres im zdf um 22 15 katrin und rudi
was erwartet uns sind ja heute abend ja
natürlich viele unglaubliche sport
momente aus dem vergangenen jahr werden
allein 48 medaillen gewinnerinnen und
gewinner aus tokio schon hier bei uns im
seien unter anderem zb die
erfolgreichste reiterin aller zeiten
isabell werth habe ich gesehen malaika
wie hamburg wurde auch schon gesichtet
die olympiasiegerin im weitsprung
triathlet patrick lange ist da die
turnerinnen und turner sind stark
vertreten mit fabian hambüchen und
elisabeth seitz nicht zu vergessen
olympiasieger im tennis alexander zverev
also unbedingt einschalten dann erfahren
sie wer sportler wer sportlerin wer
mannschaft des jahres wird ja danke euch
beiden schöne sendung später in
baden-baden und das war's vom sport
dankeschön die schon schwer in schale
gespielt sehr gut haben wir auch morgen
ist es oft sonnig im süden anfangs noch
teils dicht bewölkt später wird es auch
dort freundlicher minus zwei bis plus
sechs grad das heute journal mit
marietta slomka um viertel vor zehn wir
danken für ihr interesse wünschen ihnen
alles gute und empfehlen jetzt berlin
direkt mit theo koll